Hi, everyone.
Welcome to our first live Q&A at MoMA.
My name is Corey D'Augustine and we're going
to be taking live questions and answers for
the next 20 or 30 minutes here together.
The way this is going to work is that as you
type in questions, our producers will give
me a couple but as we have a couple of questions
lined up already from previous videos and
from the Coursera Course, why don't we jump
right to it?
First question comes from Phil Chwalinsky
and Phil asked, "Who is this guy?
He really knows his stuff?"
Thanks, Phil.
Well, just a couple of sentences about myself.
I'm an art conservator or a restorer.
I work on 20th and 21st century paintings,
sculptures.
I did that here at MoMA for about five years.
I have my own studio now.
I've taught at MoMA for six or eight years
and I teach art history at a couple different
universities here in New York City as well
as online in the Coursera Course that many
of you know about.
Next question from “PSGRIGA.”
Nice name.
Do you let the previous layers dry before
applying a new layer?
This one comes from YouTube and the Mark Rothko
video.
Sometimes.
Rothko often would paint a dry opaque layer
underneath as kind of the ground coat, the
base colors of his work before doing a lot
of glazing over them.
And again, sometimes glazing with a lot of
medium...actually, more often staining with
a lot of solvent.
Sometimes those individual stains and glazes
in the upper layers would be painted wet in
wet.
In other words, not letting the undercoat
dry.
But many times, he would work wet over dry.
He would change his paints at times working
with a lot of different additives.
So Rothko, a great technician of paint.
So again, the answer, sometimes yes, sometimes
no.
Next one from “ourtiempo” also on YouTube,
also from Mark Rothko video.
I read that besides the turpentine burn, if
Rothko used additional additives to his paints,
do you know what any of these were and the
effects they've created?
As a matter of fact, that's a great question.
It's a topic of current research.
Because Rothko, you know, almost in a way
like Leonardo da Vinci is someone who very
willingly deviated from the well understood
and the well canonized methods, techniques,
recipes for how to make a stable painting.
He didn't care so much about that as much
as he did achieving very specific aesthetic
effects.
So he used very traditional things like linseed
oil.
Also like egg, egg tempera going all the way
back to the Middle Ages.
He would mix egg into his oil sometimes, rather
unorthodox.
That's a technique called tempera grassa,
at least in the Italian Renaissance.
He also worked with animal glues.
He worked with acrylic resins, especially
later on in his career.
He worked with a thing called Magnum.
That was the first acrylic paint that Morris
Louis and other color field painters worked
with extensively.
So again, sorry, not to be ultra-specific
here, but Rothko is someone who painted in
so many different ways with so many different
materials.
But as you're starting to explore his paintings
looking at them really closely, very much
like a de Kooning you're going to find some
very interesting odd appearances of paint.
And as you start working in the studio trying
to emulate some of them or finding your own
ways through them, feel free to experiment
quite wildly and widely.
If it doesn't stick, if it cracks upon drying,
make a note of what you did and probably skip
that one next time.
But certainly, we have some great artists
who have experimented very radically away
from traditional materials and techniques.
Next one comes from de Kooning on YouTube.
This is “EllieDenise” who asked, "Can
you use olive oil on the oil color to make
it flow?
Smiley face."
Well, smiley face for me too.
Not olive oil but we do know that de Kooning
actually made great use of safflower oil,
that's kind of frying oil for your French
fries, something like that, in paintings especially
in the 1970s.
There's a great painting in the Guggenheim,
Solomon R. Guggenheim Collection here in New
York City called "Whose name was writ in water?"
It's a 1975 canvas, it's a huge canvas.
One of de Kooning's great paintings from the
70s and there's, believe it or not...you can
Google this and find an image of it but kind
of a juicy cherry red drip that is still dripping,
believe it or not.
The painting is 40 years old.
Because in that specific location there's
a lot of likely safflower oil and not so much
drying oil like linseed, it's still wet, literally.
So every couple of years, if you look at the
painting again, it's going to be another half
a centimeter, full centimeter down the painting.
It's kind of this ultimate elegy to the great
action painter William de Kooning, the drip
that keeps on dripping.
Let's see, what do we got.
Alberto from YouTube.
“I work in egg and oil tempera as we were
just talking about and I've read that a few
months after the paint cures you can seal
it with acrylic gel medium after it dries.
Could you continue painting with acrylic?”
Yeah.
The answer here is yes.
Well, as a rule of thumb, the fewer things
that you combine together, the simpler you
keep it, the more structurally sound your
painting is going to be.
In other words, if you start with oil, keep
painting with oil, chances are it's going
to a strong painting from a physical standpoint
anyway.
Same thing, you start with acrylic, keep on
painting with acrylic, great.
Now there are certain materials that combine
quite nicely like egg and oil for example.
That works pretty well.
Starting off in egg and oil, sealing it with
acrylic gel medium, continue painting with
acrylic.
I wouldn't go that route because you're working
with natural materials like egg and drying
oils, linseed oils, as a rule of thumb, I
would stick on the natural side of the fence
rather than shifting to synthetic resins like
acrylics or PVAs, polyvinyl acetates.
If I were working in that style, I'd work
with damar varnish rather than that acrylic
gel medium sealant.
Damar is a typical traditional varnish.
It comes from trees.
It's a natural resin that's going to bind
more strongly with the natural resins, egg,
linseed oil you applied underneath it.
So whereas that acrylic approach that Alberto
mentions here, it might be okay.
In the long term, I would worry about that
starting to peel or delaminate off or lead
to some cracking.
It may work but I think it's a stronger solution
to work with natural resins like damar or
mastic.
Another live question here.
This one comes from “Boycott.”
Uh-oh.
Hope you're not boycotting me.
“Can you mix oil and coat paint together?”
Related question here.
Yes and no.
De Kooning, as you may know, did a whole lot
of things that you're not supposed to do like
for example, mix safflower or water into his
oils.
Mixing oil and acrylic paint together, just
try it and you're going to know already that
you have some really uncomfortable adversaries
in your paint not working.
It's not going to flow together nicely.
It's going to get lumpy and chunky and even
if you have a whisk and you try to blend this
up, it's going to be rather frothy, unhappy
looking.
As you paint with it, it's going to change
on the surface of a painting.
It's going to settle out in a weird way as
those layers start to repel and separate from
each other.
But the ultimate, you know, answer to that
question is sure.
If you want to.
There really are no hard and fast rules for
contemporary painters to follow.
The real name of the game here is weighing
what's important to you.
If it's really important to you to make a
very structurally sound, durable painting,
then you probably don't wanna go that route.
If that weird, frothy, uncomfortable looking
texture is really what you're after, then
by all means.
If that's what does it, then put your hands...put
your faith in the hand of conservators like
myself.
You know, I've had a couple younger, younger
artists tell me with a straight face, "I consider
my work to be a collaboration with conservators."
Okay.
That keeps me in business.
I like that.
But we're pretty far away from, you know,
the times of the guild and the academies when,
you know, to be a good painter, part of that
meant making a painting that lasts for a long
time.
We're not necessarily in that moment here
in the 21st century.
Next one comes from YouTube.
How to paint like Yayoi Kusama, the Japanese
artist who's still working?
In fact, she has a retrospective at the Hirshhorn
in DC right now.
Sandy Lambert asks, "Is there a reason that
in your demonstration of creating a Kusama
painting you chose to work with oil over acrylic
rather than just sticking with acrylic paint
for the white application?"
Fair question.
Kusama certainly made some paintings all in
acrylic.
She also made a lot of paintings all in oil.
For this kind of painting for me personally,
I prefer the aesthetics, the feel, the look
of oil.
So if I had more time, I would've worked oil
over oil but as we were cranking out these
paintings in a single day, I didn't wanna
work in an oil under layer because clearly
that wouldn't dry in the same afternoon.
Then I'd be working wet in wet with a top
coat which would pick up some of the black
base layer.
So that was really just a method of expediency
but certainly, you could work acrylic over
acrylic, oil over acrylic or oil over oil.
The thing you probably don't wanna do is work
acrylic over oil because again, we have that
tendency to delaminate between layers as that
painting might age.
Next one also from YouTube, from the actually
announcement for today's Q&A.
Joe Soonthornsawad asks, "I'd love to see
a demo on Alberto Burri's combusted plastic
pieces or more realistically, a demo on glazes
and gels."
Okay, those are rather disparate topics here
but Alberto Burri, the Italian postwar painter,
a great artist and an artist who has a lot
to do with a lot of the artists that we are
focusing in, both on the YouTube videos and
in the Coursera Course.
Burri actually was an early friend of Robert
Rauschenberg and they kinda traded ideas.
Rauschenberg has a retrospective just opening
tonight, as a matter of fact, here at MoMA.
I would love to do that, that sounds like
a lot of fun to me.
Part two of that question, demo on glazes
and gels.
Yeah, we've actually had a couple of questions
about this.
You know, glazing, it's a bit, you know, hard
to wrap your mind around it originally but
as you really start to get a couple of key
fundamental ideas down, it's really not that
difficult and then once you understand this
with your hands, you start going to museums
like MoMA or like the Metropolitan probably
even better, you can really understand how
some of these paintings, these...the deep,
luminous paintings are made.
So yeah.
I hope we can do that.
Let's go to another live question from Lenny
Haskell.
“Which artist has been the most difficult
for you to study/understand/emulate with painting?”
That's an excellent question.
One of the things I'm working on right now
is thinking about how to emulate a Picasso
blue period painting for a totally different
project but maybe we'll make a video out of
that as well.
Any time you're painting with Picasso, tread
lightly.
Picasso, although he made great efforts to
paint clumsily at certain times in his career,
don't be fooled.
Picasso absolutely had the greatest hand of
any painter, any draftsman in the 20th century.
So I'm a little scared on that one for sure.
Difficult to study and understand.
Well, I don't know.
I'm not sure if I can name a specific artist.
You know, these artists who are working in
very signature styles and working...handling
materials very uniquely, specifically, like
an Ad Reinhardt like a Mark Rothko who we
were just talking about.
These artists are really challenging because
you need to start from the ground up.
Things that you think you know about paint
really well may not apply to these artists
even though they're using the same materials
but they're using them in very unique ways
or combined in different ways etcetera.
So whereas, you know, working with paintings
after the academic period for me gets way
more interesting because there's so much more
variety.
Especially as a conservator, it gets a little
bit daunting and a little bit intimidating
as it gets difficult artist by artist rather
than school by school or century by century
is the way that we really need to study.
Speaking of Ad Reinhardt, S. Newton asked
on YouTube, "It looked like you started on
a commercially stretched and primed canvas.
I'm interested in the mat, no brushstroke
finish and I'm wondering if there's more to
the prep of the canvas than shown here.
Can you tell me?"
Yes and no.
As a matter of fact, I did work on a commercially
primed canvas that day.
Reinhardt did that occasionally but in fact,
most of the time, Reinhardt sized, stretched,
and primed his canvas himself.
His daughter actually told me she remembers
the smell of boiling rabbit skin glue.
I think she helped him cook that sometimes
in the studio.
So he worked with very traditional size layer
before applying usually an oil ground to his
paintings.
In my experiments working with Reinhardt type
finishes, the ground is not that important
to the finish.
It's really specifically how you handle that
paint.
I've been able to get a pretty close surface
to a Reinhardt painting and for me I think
that the critical issue here is really the
pigment to binder ratio, drawing a lot of
that linseed oil out of the paint, preserving
the kind of a homogenous, even feel of that
paint but then really getting a nice light
brushstroke with a lot of solvent in there,
allowing that paint to settle out nicely.
Don't stay on it too long or you're going
to be leaving these tracks behind your brush.
But here's a great example of an artist who...if
you first look at his paintings, you may think,
"Well, this is so simple.
Anyone can paint like that.
it's just flat black."
But it's a really unique type of beautiful
velvet quality of paint and it's actually
very, very difficult as I'm sure all my students
on Coursera who have gotten that far in the
course can attest.
I think that's probably the most difficult
week of all the weeks from a technical perspective
in the Coursera Course.
Another question on Ad Reinhardt.
Mister Fancy Pants writes, "Respect to the
artist."
Couldn't agree more.
"But was I the only one to chuckle when he
said there is no black in this painting and
then proceeds to add black to the painting?"
Oh, he's talking about me.
Yeah, maybe I overspoke a little bit.
The key there...he's adding black pigment,
sure, but in the finished work, you're actually
not looking at any blacks.
You're looking at really deep shades of other
colors like red and green and blue.
Of course, to get those deep shades, you're
adding a lot of, in this case, mars black
paint there.
So I guess you were right to chuckle.
I probably should've been a little bit more
clear about that.
Coursera student, Constantina Yiokari asks,
"What would you use to prime, for example,
wood or metal, materials other than canvas?"
A really good question.
Well, wood, this is a pretty time-tested answer
since of course in the northern and southern
Renaissance, we have many painters working
on panels, oak and hardwood to the north,
poplar and Southwood in the south.
Gesso is the great material to prime wood.
Traditional gesso is rabbit skin glue with
gypsum or chalk, calcium sulfate, something
like that mixed in.
That works great.
Always has, always will.
You can also work with an acrylic gesso on
wood.
No problem at all.
If you're working on metal, this is a little
bit trickier since a lot of paints and painting
materials don't adhere particularly well to
metal.
So the first step is you probably wanna etch
that metal with acid.
Okay.
I'm not sure if you're going to be working
with that in your studio.
Or you can really abrade the surface with
a metal scour and pad or something like that.
The point here is that if metal's really slick,
it doesn't have any tooth for a paint to really
bind onto, so by physically roughing up the
surface, that's definitely a good idea working
in your advantage.
And then what kind of primers would you work
on that?
I might steer you towards a commercial primer
for metal now.
There's a specific acrylic resin called B67.
Don't worry about it.
Or it should be 48N.
Regardless, acrylic...certain acrylic resins
are formulated to adhere to metal better.
Don't go out and buy that resin necessarily
but you can find commercial products often
spray things or brush things like Rust-Oleum
products which are made for adhering to metal
and then that primer is well built for receiving
other paints like traditional acrylic emulsion
paints enamel paints or even oil paints.
Live question on the Q&A from Rachel Grodsky.
Rachel says, "It seems like the painters either
landed in action painting or not.
Why didn't they mix action with other styles
or are there such examples?"
There are in fact other examples but the landed
in action painting part, I like that.
it does seem like it happened all rather quickly
and part of the reason if we can, you know,
open up the historic lens here for a moment,
is that many of these painters working in
New York City and elsewhere by the way but
many of them in New York City were really
trying to find a new style.
They were working very much in the shadow
of European surrealism and cubism and constructivism,
all of these styles from the old world.
And they were really trying to break out and
find something new.
And it's not that one artist did that but
Pollock and de Kooning are most often credited
with making the breakthrough which was really
a synthetic one.
Drawing upon European precedent for sure,
drawing on Mexican muralists, David Alfaro
Siqueiros who had an experimental art workshop
here in Lower Manhattan.
But then really using the body and the body
in a big, gestural, athletic, dancer like
kind of way was a new idea, a non-European
idea.
And once that idea became in the air, so to
speak, a lot of artists were really quick
to pick it up because this became a real New
York style, a real American style, something
really new and exciting.
Part two of that question, "Are there mixes
with other styles?"
Yeah, sure.
Arshile Gorky, interesting artist who unfortunately
ended his own life in 1948 way too early was
working with a, you know, modest kind of gestural
kind of paint but also thinking very much
about surrealism and biomorphic abstraction.
Biomorphic, this word means, you know, shapes
found in nature.
So looking at plants really closely, painting
things that are abstract but look kind of
like leaves or look kind of like a paramecium
or an amoeba or something like that but doing
so in the gestural physical kind of painterly
manner.
Question on Mark Rothko from Mike Dusch, "I
was hoping for some tips and insights on how
to adopt Rothko's oil techniques into acrylic
paint.
Any advice from you, more veteran painters,
would be appreciated.
I'm absolutely loving the courses.
Thanks."
Thanks, Mike.
Well, actually, Rothko himself was looking
for those same insights.
Rothko, towards the end of his life...he passed
away in 1970.
The last...and I'm not exactly sure.
Four or five years, something like that, of
his career, he worked extensively with acrylics.
A more minimal approach than the more painterly
things early in his career.
But certainly, I've had students working in
Rothko's style in acrylic emulsions to have
really, really good results.
The difference is to get those stains, you're
no longer cutting oils with turpentine or
mineral spirits but you're cutting your acrylic
emulsion paints, your liquitex or what have
you, golden paints with water.
And that water is then going to allow you
to have kind of a liquid, Kool-Aid consistency
of your paint which you can stain and really
scrub into the canvas.
Now, the big difference here between using
water to cut your paint versus the organic
spirits is surface tension.
So turpentine is going to really flow nicely
and evenly into your support whereas water,
as you know, if you drip some water on a table,
it beads up.
It has surface tension to it.
So you might need to be a little bit more
aggressive brushing that, forcing it down
into the canvas or into the underlying paint
layer because otherwise, it may bead up and
have a little bit of a resist effect.
But certainly, by spending a little bit more
time and energy on some vigorous brushwork,
you can absolutely get some extremely Rothko
like effects with those thinned down acrylic
emulsions.
Question from Mary Cooper.
Question's about protecting acrylic and oil
paintings once they're finished.
“I’ve seen various sprays advertised in
art supplies catalogues for protecting finished
pieces against ultraviolet light, etc.
What would be the recommended way to protect
paintings to make them last longer and are
there any products to be aware of that alter
color over time etc?”
This is actually a huge question and we're
just going to scratch the surface, if you'll
forgive the pun here.
For many, many years, there has been this
kind of misconception that varnishes protect
a painting and some of you are probably saying,
"Oh, my professor in such and such art school
said exactly that."
Very rarely does a varnish actually protect
anything.
As a matter of fact, varnishes have damaged
more paintings or the restorer trying to get
that varnish off has damaged many more paintings
than varnishes actually protected.
I promise.
So varnishes are really an aesthetic choice
here 99%.
A frame, a sheet of plexi or glass over your...now
we're talking about protecting your painting
really but a varnish...every varnish is going
to change color over time.
If you're working with a natural resin like
damar or varnish...sorry, damar or mastic
varnish, these turn yellow gradually and,
you know, 25 years down the road, you're probably
going to want to take that off and put a new
one on.
That's a tricky job for certain paintings,
definitely a job for a conservator.
If you're working with one of these newer
synthetic resin varnishes, acrylics and whatnot,
many of these don't turn yellow but they kind
of gray out or become foggy or milky looking
over time.
And again, 20, 25, 30 years down the road,
you probably wanna take that off and put another
one on.
This whole taking off and putting it on part,
this is tricky and for certain kind of paintings,
it's impossible to do safely.
So my own advice here.
if you're using a varnish for aesthetic purposes,
by all means, run with it.
If you're really thinking that it's just some
necessary coat that you have to do to make
a finished painting, it's really a fallacy
that unfortunately continues to be spread
today.
So I'd really skip it if the look of a varnish
is not something you're interested in.
Next one comes from Eva Brenda Rodriguez Paredes
on Coursera.
“How can a contemporary painter part from
postwar abstractionism into something that
reflects his own identity rather than just
a derivative approach from the artists we
are currently analyzing?"
The $25,000 question.
That's up to you really but I really don't
think...especially developing artists should
worry about working in the styles of other
artists because in doing that, invariably,
you're not going to make a copy.
You're not going to make a Rothko that looks
just like Rothko or even a Pollock or what
have you.
Instead, what you're going to do is you're
going to find out how your own hand does things
differently and before you start saying, "Oh,
it's not as good as a Rothko."
Just realize it's different than a Rothko.
And some things you may have inadvertently
done are more you than Rothko and actually
these are going to find some...they're going
to provide some creative pathways forward.
So I would suggest absolutely painting through
the masters, right.
So learning about the painters that you really
like, learning about their materials, their
approaches, their techniques, etc. trying
your hand at it and then finding out actually
it wasn't all of Rothko's approach that I
liked.
It was just this one facet which is going
to provide an avenue into your own work.
And by the way, don't worry about working
in someone else's style.
Pablo Picasso had a great quote.
He said, "Good artists borrow.
Great artists steal."
Nice.
So go ahead.
Be a great artist.
Steal something, make it your own and in fact,
the history of painting is full of this kind
of thing.
So as long as you're not, you know, lifting
an image or something like that, you know,
the style of Richard Prince or Andy Warhol
and copyright infringement and all that, I
really wouldn't worry about this at all.
You will find your way for sure.
And by the way, Arshile Gorky, who we just
mentioned a few minutes ago, did exactly that.
As a young artist here in New York City, in
New Jersey, he basically was with Picasso
for a time in the same way that you might
be with a boyfriend or a girlfriend or something
like that and he was with Miró for a while
and with Kandinsky for a while and he wore
his influences on his sleeve.
And by the time he was done with all these
withs, if you will, he realized that a little
of this and a little of that and a pinch of
salt and a twist of lemon and suddenly, Gorky
has a very original language which is all
him.
The idea of finding a signature style out
of nothing is kind of a ridiculous idea here
in the 21st century.
So there's no reason not to borrow heavily
from all these great historical sources that
we have.
It's part of the reason we study art history,
by the way.
“ZiggytotheMoon” asks, "Are there any
rare color pigments that are very rare or
not used by artists anymore?"
In fact, there are many of these.
There's one really rare color called Indian
yellow which I believe is distilled from the
urine of cows who eat a lot of mango leaves
in India.
I couldn't make that up, I promise.
So anyway, that's kind of rare.
There are a lot of extinct paints out there.
very few artists still work with lead white
because lead is somewhat toxic.
It's a little bit overblown as long as you're
not eating the paint or something like that.
it's a problem.
Now, if your walls are, you know, powdering
lead white and it's getting in your food and
you're breathing it, that is a problem.
But there's another color, emerald green.
A beautiful green, Paris green, it's also
called.
A French color from the 19th century.
Believe it or not, that is rat poison and
as that pigment was patented, it was patented
as a beautiful green pigment and as rat poison
at the same time.
So yeah.
You probably don't wanna be working with that
and getting that all over your hands.
So that one, I don't know anyone who supplies
that now.
You'd have to dig a little bit.
But there are some out there.
But certainly, with some research, actually,
you'll find many more than just those two
that I mentioned.
Jenny Gunnerson asks...in fact, she asked
two questions, "What is the difference between
binder and solvent and what is the difference..."
Well, let's tackle that first question first,
binder and solvent.
So binder is the glue or the vehicle of a
paint.
It's the stuff that's already in your tube.
In other words, in an oil paint, that's linseed
oil.
The solvent is the thinner for it.
So in the world of oil paint, the typical
historical solvent is turpentine.
That's a tree distilled resin.
It's the thing that takes your oil and really
dissolves it, okay.
So if you're working with a liquitex or golden
acrylic emulsion, your binder is in fact that
acrylic resin, a synthetic resin and your
solvent, the thinner is now just water, okay.
And secondly, "What is the difference between
color value, chroma, and saturation?
Hope someone out there can help me out.
Thanks."
Couple suggestions here.
There is a little video on the Coursera Course
so you might take a look at that one.
You might also take a look...go onto Wikipedia
and check out Muncell, that's M-U-N-C-E-L-L,
Muncell color space.
You'll find a really, really nicely written
site that explores Muncell color theory.
Some people really dorked out there.
Thanks to those guys and gals.
Essentially, value is the darkness of a color.
So you're looking at a color, you're looking
at this painting back here but imagine you're
seeing it just in grayscale.
You're in Photoshop and you've turned down,
you know, all the colors.
So it's how dark a shade of that gray is it.
Chroma is the purity of a color.
In other words, you're talking about a yellow.
How much other stuff besides yellow is in
there?
Is it a screaming, brilliant yellow, high
chroma?
Or is it kind of a muddy, oakerish you know,
muted kind of a yellow, low chroma?
And saturation.
Saturation, the term that a lot of people
use but not that many people actually know
what it means.
Saturation is the wet appearance of a color.
So you know, Asphalt street, right?
In fact, it's kind of like dark gray or something
like that but when it rains, suddenly it looks
black.
That's the saturated color of that unsaturated
dark gray of the asphalt.
In fact, paintings work the same way.
In fact, the aesthetic reason that most artists
use a varnish is because they wanna re-saturate
those colors, make them look wet again after
they dried.
So the whole saturated business is very critical
to traditional painting, perspectival painting
because it...when you evenly saturate all
those colors, suddenly you have the ability
to project some illusionistic space behind
the picture plane.
That picture frame turns into a window frame.
You can imagine looking out into the distance
into a, say, a Tissen painting or Vermeer
or something like that.
In the 20th and 21st centuries, this becomes
more of an issue about the surface of a painting.
Picasso making some glossy marks and some
mat marks so your eye knows that, "Oh, these
are things that are marks made on a flat surface."
So a lot of different ways to handle that
but essentially, yes.
Saturated means the wet version of whatever
color that you're talking about.
And I think maybe our last question here which
comes from Instagram from Felixblanzy says,
"Hi, thanks for your videos, very instructive.
Could you talk about thin, straight lines
technique in acrylic or oil?"
Thin, straight lines.
Okay, a couple of different ways to do this.
Barnett Newman made a lot of thin, straight
lines.
Some thick, straight lines also that he called
zips working with masking tape.
So to do that, you could take two pieces of
masking tape, leave just a thin space between
them.
Before you paint that space, really make sure
that that masking tape is well adhered to
the canvas.
Otherwise, paint is going to bleed under that
masking tape.
But then you can use a brush or a knife and
make that mark over those two pieces of tape,
critically over that gap between them.
Take off the two pieces of paint...of tape
rather while the paint is wet still.
That's fine.
And you should be left with a very crisp line
in between.
Many artists use this.
Piet Mondrian famously did a whole lot of
this.
There's a kind of characteristic look to a
masked line however.
You could get a little lip of paint...I'm
actually working on a Gerhard Richter painting
where the whole thing is full of these lips
where there's a little thickness of paint
right where that masking tape was.
So if you don't wanna do that, if you don't
wanna get that characteristic effect, well,
now you've gotta practice a lot.
There are brushes out there called lining
brushes.
In fact, de Kooning worked with these as a
kid when he went to trade school, art school
and he in fact, introduced that kind of brush
to Arshile Gorky.
And if you look at Gorky's paintings, you'll
find very beautiful black sinuous thin lines.
Not straight lines in his case but gorgeously
executed thin ones.
A lining brush comes to a really nice, fine
point but they have really long bristles before
the ferrule brush so that you can hold a lot
of paint.
The reason that's important...if you can make
a long continuous line without having to reload
your brush and then, you know, replace the
point which is going to give you kind of a
chattering line.
So yeah.
Making a straight line freehand.
Well, now you're talking about, you know,
really great draftsmen and painters.
So the easy way out is masking tape but there's
a caveat that has a kind of masked look to
it for sure.
We do have a couple of more live questions,
it looks like here.
This one's from YouTube from Katie Frank,
"Please tell us more about your personal artwork."
These days, you know, I haven't spent a whole
lot of time at the aisle because I've spent
a lot of work as a conservator and teaching.
When I was making a ton of work in the studio,
I made mostly abstract paintings where I didn't
really work with paint per se but chose to
use other everyday materials and find ways
for them to behave like paint.
For example, taking iron shavings, finding
a way to fuse them onto canvas and then working
with different kinds of acid to dissolve that
and repatinate the surface.
Or working with makeup.
Makeup is something that looks a whole lot
like paint actually but it never dries.
As a matter of fact, speaking of saturation
or thinking about our chroma, it's possible
to get more chromatic or more saturated colors
with silicon binder of a lot of makeups than
it is with oil because it stays wet.
Of course, those little fingerprints get all
over the place too.
Anyway, maybe more on that some other time.
Question from Foster Atkinson, "We're just
going to ignore the fact that this guy looks
like Drake?"
I learned this from the YouTube videos.
Actually, I did hear that once before.
I could do worse, I guess, right?
I'm more of a Kendrick Lamar guy but, you
know, I'll take that as a compliment.
Thanks, Foster Atkinson.
Anvita Mathu: “So Drake's a painter now?”
Thanks.
Yeah, yeah.
If it is another Drake one.
What do we got?
Renaldo Rodriguez says, "Are you Drake's lost
brother?"
I don't know about that but it's starting
to look likely, I guess.
Yes.
I can guess.
No.
No more on Drake.
Okay.
So let's wrap up here.
We've had some requests for additional contents,
more videos etc. are coming up.
IN THE STUDIO videos, we've actually had a
couple...more than a couple of people request
a part two of a William de Kooning video.
You see where I left off in part one behind
me.
And I mentioned in that video on YouTube and
on Coursera that a de Kooning painting is
never made in one afternoon, no way.
In fact, he sometimes spent months or even
years on his canvases so this work necessarily
looks really thin and fresh whereas a real
de Kooning painting is very labor intensive
and very heavy.
In fact, we're going to do that.
I'm going to talk about a couple ways that
de Kooning would move on from week to week
or day to day by scraping, physically dry
paint.
Scraping it off the canvas.
And also by working temporarily or permanently
with collage elements in the canvas making
a drawing, putting that drawing on the canvas,
painting over it, you know, extending some
of those lines, maybe taking the drawing back
off or maybe leaving it there.
So absolutely stay tuned for that one.
“TheeArtChick,” nice name.
“Would you do a painting a la fauve style?
Love this channel.
Have learned so much.
Thanks.”
Yeah, absolutely.
Fauve, the movement, it means wild beast in
French.
That's Henri Matisse, his followers, Maurice
de Vlaminck, Derain, artists like that.
Fauve technique is actually quite straightforward.
So this is one that I think we really should
do and this is a great kind of beginning modern
painting style.
Most fauves wild beasts, they painted wet
in wet.
Very direct painting technique.
Straight out of the tubes at times.
They really admired the paintings of children,
finger painting.
Very simple looking paintings but there's
really nothing simple about a Matisse as we'll
find out.
“Rossinaround” says, "Hello.
As an aspiring painter living in Tokyo, I
love the how to paint like Yayoi Kusama video.
Any chance you can do a how to paint like
Picasso in his abstract works or Jean-Michel
Basquiat Thanks?"
In fact, Picasso never made an abstract painting,
believe it or not.
Although he came pretty damn close.
In fact, we are going to do this.
We are going to make a cubism video.
Anyway, not specifically Picasso but also
Georges Braque who also gets left out but
was absolutely 50% of the invention of cubism.
I think this is going to be really strong
video because in making a cubist drawing and
then a painting, you're really going to understand
what cubism is all about.
It's going to help you look at a cubist painting
and really appreciate cubism.
One of the really most important movements
of the entire 20th century.
Basquiat, interesting one also.
Next one.
Please do one on Basquiat.
Michael Augusto, Jean-Michel Basquiat please.
Okay, I get it.
Basquiat who is doing extremely well in museums
and auction houses these days...really interesting
artist who, like Rauschenberg, like many other
artists felt extremely free to do anything
and everything with any kind of material,
any kind of paint etc.
So in a way, this is a hard one because there
isn't one Basquiat style at all to choose
from but certainly, we can look at some of
the materials he painted on, some very unorthodox
choices of supports.
I worked on a painting recently that's stretched
over a pallet, like a wooden pallet.
Not on a painter's pallet but a wooden pallet
for like moving furniture and things like
that.
looked great on the back.
Almost as great as it did on the front.
And we can talk about some of the enamels
that he worked with and oil stick and some
of the other effects that he went back to
again and again.
So absolutely.
Let's do it.
Make a Guston.
We also received a lot a lot of Guston requests.
I think that's a great idea.
Phil Guston, an artist who started out as
a figurative painter, was a kind of relative
late comer to abstraction circa 1952, '53
here in New York City and then actually was
one of the first New York school painters
to really lose faith in abstraction and return
to figuration before making some really interesting
paintings in 1970s where he's thinking about
cartoons and sarcasm and satire etc.
Guston is one of my favorite painters.
I'd love to talk about some of the continuity
between his abstract works and then some of
his later figurative works which for all their
crassness, their lowbrow humor, were actually
really gorgeously painted more often than
not.
Bridget Reilly, Robert Motherwell, Clifford
Still, Gustaf Klimt, Helen Frankenthaler,
lots of really interesting artists that people
are requesting here.
By all means, keep requests coming and as
we start to find, you know, more interest
in certain areas than others, I will absolutely
take that into consideration.
So yeah.
Looks like we have a cubism video, a de Kooning
video on the way.
Click on subscribe down below.
You'll be sure not to miss those videos when
they pop up.
If we didn't get to your questions in the
video, we'll try answering some of them in
text in the various discussion forums here
on YouTube or on Coursera.
And by all means, keep those questions coming
as well.
also, let us know if you like this session.
I'd be happy to do more of them if this kind
of thing is useful or fun, if this is better
than, you know, clicking away on the keyboard
and getting responses in text, you know, a
couple days or a week later.
If there's interest, let us know.
So thanks for tuning in.
Keep sending questions and thanks again for
watching IN THE STUDIO.